AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
LADIES NIGHT.
EXCLAMATION POINT.
>> YEAH.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: AS YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED THE PANEL TONIGHT IS
ALL FEMALE AND I DID WANT TO
POINT OUT, THAT IN COMEDY,
THERE IS THIS REALLY WEIRD
PHENOMENON THAT WHEN A
COMEDY, WHEN A STAND-UP
COMEDY SHOW IS ALL FEMALE,
THEY GIVE IT TERRIBLE NAMES.
TERRIBLE, LIKE JUST TO LET
YOU KNOW IT'S AN ALL-FEMALE
COMEDY SHOW.
USUALLY PRETTY DERISIVE AND
[BLEEP] AND HORRIBLE.
YOU GUYS PERFORM ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE PROBABLY BEEN TO
COMEDY CLUBS THAT HAVE THESE
HORRIBLE, HORRIBLE, CRINGEY
LADIES NIGHT NAMES LIKE
"CHICKS AND GIGGLES" OR
"LAUGHIA MAJORA" OR "ONE IN THE
PINK MINIMUM, TWO IN THE
DRINK MINIMUM."
YOU KNOW WHAT'S ANOTHER TERM FOR
FUNNY FEMALE COMEDIANS?
"FUNNY COMEDIANS."
BUT THESE CLUBS COULDN'T
POSSIBLY HOST AN ALL-FEMALE
LINE-UP AND NOT REFERENCE
WHITE WINE AND VULVA PARTS,
SO COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO COME UP WITH AS MANY TERRIBLE
NAMES AS YOU CAN FOR CHEESY
COMEDY CLUB LADIES NIGHTS.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
BRIDEY.
>> [BLEEP] ON MY BITS.
>> Chris: POINTS. LENNON.
>> EAT, PRAY, LAUGH.
>> Chris: POINTS.
LENNON.
>> MUCH ADO ABOUT MUFFIN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> JESSICA.
>> DIAPHRAGM BAM THANK YOU
MA'AM.
>> Chris: POINTS.
BRIDEY.
>> GIGGLE TILL YOU SQUIRT.
>> Chris: LENNON.
>> AT YOUR CERVIX.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JESSICA.
>> JESTROGEN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
LENNON.
>> DOES THE COMEDY MATCH THE
DRAPES?
>> Chris: POINTS. JESSICA.
>> GLEE BAGGING.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
>> GIRLS JUST WANT TO HAVE
PUN.
>> Chris: YES, PERFECT.